vous avez rendu un avis que de surcroît
qui au plus vite depuis ce matin je vous
en remercie et les verts nous l'expliqué
elle en riant deux rapporteurs dans ce
texte dans notre commission hervé qui
est ici bien sûr et monsieur marc
philippe daubresse qui doit être en
visioconférence si la technique ne nous
a pas trahi il a bon c'est parfait nous
avons petites heures de travail
en tous les cas nous souhaitons vous
entends sur votre avis quelle serait la
parole aux rapporteurs ensuite
et puis ceux qui souhaiteront en la
parole de façon à ce que chacun puisse
s'exprimer
voilà très bien à madame robert qui doit
être moqué membres des sénatrices membre
de la commission est avec nous mais les
connectés par visioconférence travers
mais je crois que vous la connaissez
déjà là et bien vous avez la parole
valable et on va aux dix ans présentent
à nous pour le retard mais elle merci
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
le président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie de donner à
la cnil
l'occasion de venir présenter devant les
membres de la commission des lois
l'avis rendu par le collège sur la
proposition de loi relative à la
sécurité globale
lors de la dernière séance plénière je
suis accompagné par lui dutheillet de
lamothe qui est secrétaire général de la
cnil est paré mini sirugue à coke et la
chef du service des affaires régaliennes
et des collectivités territoriales
avant de détailler les thèmes abordés
dans notre avis sur cette ppl je
voudrais dire un mot mais le président
sur le caractère novateur de la démarche
suivie par la commission des lois du
sénat
c'est en effet la première fois qu'il
est fait usage des nouvelles
dispositions de l'article 8 de la loi du
6 janvier 1978
produite par une loi récente du 20 juin
2018 qui donne la faculté au président
de l'assemblée nationale au président du
sénat aux présidents des commissions
permanentes ou bien encore au président
délais d'un groupe parlementaire de
saisir pour avis
la cnil sur une proposition de loi je
crois que c'était particulièrement
opportun sur ce texte et j'espère que la
vie délibéré par le collège de la cnil
éclairera vos débats ce texte contient
en effet plusieurs dispositions qui
relèvent du cadre informatique et
libertés et qui pose des enjeux
significative juridiques et techniques
mais aussi éthique et je m'arrête un
instant seulement parce que ça n'est pas
le coeur de notre avis sur ces derniers
aspects nous avons tenu à souligner dans
notre délibération les implications
éthiques
attaché au déploiement d'outils
présentant intrinsèquement des risques
d'atteinte aux libertés publiques et à
la vie privée des individus
j'en viens maintenant à l'analyse
développée dans notre avis nous avons
suivi une démarche somme toute classique
en nous attachant à la recherche de
l'équilibré le plus respectueux des
intérêts en cause préserver les
finalités légitime de la sécurité
publique tout en garantissant la
protection de la vie privée
j'insiste sur un point c'est
naturellement au parlement qui revient
de retenir ou non une finalité par un
choix qui est de nature politique
nous nous nous sommes attachés à
vérifier si les finalités prévu par la
proposition de loi réponde à certaines
exigences juridiques pour nous assurer
qu'elles sont suffisamment précise et
que l' usage des drones ou d'autres
formes de vidéo apparaît proportionnée
et suffisamment encadré à cet égard je
voudrais souligner trois points avant
d'entrer dans les détails de notre
analyse
tout d'abord la cnil salue le fait que
soit discuté un encadrement législatif
de ces systèmes qui jusqu'à présent n'en
disposez pas s'agissant des caméras zae
reporter plus couramment appelé drones
même si la notion principe désigner de
drones et les ducs tri depuis plusieurs
années la cnil appelait de ses voeux un
tel encadrement
je saisis néanmoins l'occasion pour
rappeler plus globalement que
l'encadrement de l'ensemble des
dispositifs de vidéoprotection et pas
des soldes rhône demeure incomplet
puisque les dispositions du code de la
sécurité intérieure relatives à la
vidéoprotection sont en partie obsolètes
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du rgp des et
mérite d'être globalement repensé
ensuite nous constatons que le recours
accentuée ces dernières années à des
dispositifs technologiques de plus en
plus performants en particulier dans le
domaine de la vidéo et décider sans que
l'efficacité de ces systèmes net été
démontrée nikos et dispositif n'est fait
l'objet d'une évaluation rigoureuse
enfin je précise que le jeu je
n'aborderai pas l avis de la cnil non
plus tous les points tous les sujets
inscrits dans la proposition de loi mais
on se concentre sur ce qui relève de nos
compétences ainsi s'agissant de
l'article 24 relatif à la pénalisation
comme vous le savez de la diffusion
d'image des forces de l'ordre dans le
but manifeste qu'il soit porté atteinte
à leur intégrité physique ou psychique
notre avis ne s'est pas étendu sur un
dispositif qui est principalement
appréhendée sous l'angle pénale même
s'il rappelle que l'enregistrement et la
diffusion des images captées dans ce
cadre constitue un traitement de données
à caractère personnel
ses explications et en apporter gens
dire maintenant aux principales
observations de notre avis en commençant
par le sujet qui suscite qui a suscité
en tout cas la tension particulière du
collège de la cnil celui des caméras
aéroportée alors s'agissant des drones
je procéderai en trois temps des
remarques générales la question des
finalités puis celle des garanties en
l'état actuel comme vous savez
l'encadrement est inexistant
le choix de recourir à ce dispositif
présente des enjeux substantielles en
matière de vie privée et pour l'exercice
d'autres libertés fondamentales il ne
faut pas sous-estimer les difficultés
qu'il ya à transposer les règles
applicables à des systèmes de
vidéoprotection classique et à ce type
de dispositif les drones qui sont tout
sauf anodin
les caméras aéroportée sont en effet par
nature discrète mobile et furtives leur
position en hauteur permet de filmer des
lieux qui jusqu'ici était difficile
d'accès la captation d'imagés donc
considérablement élargi et surtout peut
être individualisée permettant le suivi
des personnes y compris sur une durée
qui peut être vue en baisse les drones
permettent ainsi en théorie
l'identification de toute personne
circulant dans l'espace public alors
même que cet espace public et
le où s'exerce de nombreuses libertés
publiques et individuelles le droit de
manifester la liberté de culte la
liberté d'expression enfin ils sont ils
peuvent
incontestablement être utilisé à des
finalités légitime mais il faut aussi
tenir compte de ce qu'il représente dans
l'imaginaire collectif que peut
ressentir le citoyen qu'il aperçoit ou
pense le voir passer au dessus de lui
donc son changement de paradigme
participent des débats plus large autour
de la société de surveillance je ne
m'attarde pas sur ce contexte où sur ce
débat global mais j'insiste sur la
nécessité de traiter le sujet
méthodiquement c'est-à-dire d'abord en
déterminant précisément les finalités
pour lesquelles on accepte de recourir à
des drones qu'ils ensuite pour chacune
de ces finalités en s'assurant que les
circonstances précises des missions
menées justifie l'emploi de ces
dispositifs et enfin en s'attachant à
prévoir les garanties appropriées à
mettre en oeuvre
alors j'en viens maintenant à la liste
des finalités pour lesquelles la
proposition de loi prévoit que les
drones pourront être utilisés salissant
tout d'abord du constat et de la
poursuite d'infractions
la commission estime la commission
femmes modestement la neutralité il
estime que la proposition de loi ou les
dispositions réglementaires clients
découleront doivent impérativement
définir plus précisément les infractions
susceptibles de justifier l'utilisation
des caméras zae reporter c'est le double
verrou que nous évoquons dans notre
délibération de la nécessité le drone
est il utile à la lutte contre toutes
les infractions prévues par le code
pénal ou seulement
pour certaines d'entre elles est le
deuxième verrou c'est celui de la
proportionnalité est il raisonnable de
recourir à l'identification par drones
de toute personne dans la rue pour
constater des contraventions de 5e
classe
une autre finalité qui est prévu par le
texte et celle de la surveillance des
rassemblements des personnes qui est
particulièrement délicate puisqu'elle
intervient dans le champ de l'exercice
de la liberté de manifester et la
commission estime à cet égard que des
critères plus resserrée doivent être
prévues notamment ceux qui concernent la
condition de risques de troubles graves
à l'ordre public pour d'autres finalités
le recours aux drones n'apparaît pas
clairement justifié dans toute leur
généralité
il en va ainsi pour les objectifs qui
sont rédigées de manière générique comme
je cite la protection des bâtiments et
installations publiques et de leurs
abords ou le secours aux personnes
les formulations pourrait être
restreinte il peut en effet apparaître
plus justifiée de recourir à ces
dispositifs intrusif pour protéger le
site du sénat ou celui de l'elysée que
pour assurer la sécurité des abords
immédiats du musée de la vie romantique
à paris de très beaux musées
par ailleurs il en est de même
s'agissant jeu s'il de la surveillance
des littoraux et des zones frontalières
la commission estime qu'il convient de
ne pas se limiter à définir la finalité
par tout type de surveillance sur une
zone géographique donnée mais d'indiquer
à quelle fin cette surveillance par
drones aux frontières pourra être
déployée
certains finalité mérite aussi d'être
explicités comme par exemple celle
relative à la prévention des risques
naturels et technologiques afin de
démontrer la nécessité du recours aux
drones à cette fin il conviendrait d'en
restreindre l'utilisation à des types de
situations dans lesquelles les
circonstances de l'intervention le
justifie par exemple pour accéder à des
lieux difficiles ou présentant un danger
particulier par ailleurs une seconde
réserve nous semble s'imposer pour les
usages pour lesquels la nécessité est
établie il convient de s'assurer que les
circonstances précises des missions me
justifie au cas d'espèce l'emploi de ces
dispositifs une même finalité
correspondant à de nombreux cas des
usages possibles dont certains ne
justifie pas le recours aux drones donc
il ne s'agit pas dans notre esprit de
prévoir l'ensemble des cas de figure
dans la loi ou dans le décret mais nous
suggérons que les précisions normatif
qui pourront être apportées s'accompagne
de la publication par les responsables
de traitement d'une doctrine d'usagé des
drones en quelque sorte des lignes
directrices établies à l'intention des
services pour les guider afin de
déterminer les cas pour lesquels il est
proportionnée de recourir à des drones
au delà de la détermination explicite
des finalités la cnil estime que des
garanties complémentaires pour la mise
en oeuvre de ces drones devront être
apportées au niveau réglementaire dans
le décret en conseil d'état qui sera
soumis pour avis à la cnil en
particulier des garanties techniques
devront être prévues afin de s'assurer
de l'absence de possibilité
d'identification ou d'enregistrement
pour certains usages qui ne nécessite
pas de procéder à l'identification des
personnes comme par exemple pour la
régulation des flux de transport
en août la question de l'information du
public et de son effectivité a fait
l'objet d'un développement spécifique
dans notre avis auquel je me permets de
renvoyer
enfin et c'est un peu un point important
pour toutes ces raisons le collège de la
cnil souhaite que s'il le juge opportun
évidemment le législateur conditionne
l'utilisation des caméras zae reportée à
une expérimentation préalables dont la
durée serait limitée dans le temps et
dont il conviendrait de tirer toutes les
conséquences dans un bilan qui serait
transmis au parlement et dont la cnil
serait également destinataire j'en viens
à présent aux autres technologies abordé
dans la ppl mais sans entrer dans des
détails trop techniques
alors tout d'abord en ce qui concerne
les caméras individuelle des forces de
l'ordre ces dispositifs ne sont pas
nouveaux pour la cnil
le site informer le public sur les
circonstances de l'intervention fin de
citation la cnil comprend qu'il peut y
avoir là une utilité pour permettre une
forme de transparence vis-à-vis des
conditions d'intervention des forces de
l'otan en particulier lorsqu'elles sont
mises en cause
cependant nous insistons aussi sur le
fait qu'il n'est pas anodin de diffuser
ainsi publiquement
des images prises généralement dans
l'espace public qui puisait dans les
circonstances d'une intervention
policière et nous pensons qu'il faut
davantage précisé les motifs qui
justifient cette diffusion et prévoir
des garanties plus précises notamment
pour flouter ce qui peut l'être
mais le principal changement dans les
cas d'utilisation des dispositifs des
caméras individuel réside dans la
possibilité désormais offerte aux agents
de la police nationale de la gendarmerie
nationale et de la police municipale
d'accéder directement aux
enregistrements auxquels il procède dans
le cadre d'une procédure judiciaire ou
d'une intervention
une telle modification apparaît légitime
dans le cadre d'une procédure judiciaire
afin par exemple d'établir un rapport le
plus précis possible mais pas
nécessairement dans tous les cas de
figure donc la cnil a insisté dans son
don son avis sur la nécessité de
préserver la sécurité et l'intégrité des
images transmises et à s'assurer que
celles-ci ne feront pas l'objet d'une
visualisation sans motif légitime ni
d'une modification ni d'une suppression
alors maintenant si l'on considère la
vidéoprotection dans son ensemble nous
observons une extension des accès aux
images de vidéo protection
donc les lieux ouverts au public ou sur
ou sur la voie publique ce qui doit m'a
en tout cas conduire à maintenir des
garanties fortes d accès restreint des
habilitations strict par exemple pour
l'accès à ses images
j'insisterai au stade de ce propos
liminaires sur deux sujets seulement la
modification du code de la construction
et de l'habitation qui permet de
collecter de manière plus large les
images des systèmes installés qui sont
installées dans les parties communes des
immeubles collectifs à usage
d'habitation
la cnil s'est interrogé sur les
insuffisances du dispositif actuel qui
justifie un tel est là
glissement des modalités de transmission
des images aux forces de l'ordre
la transmission n'étant plus subordonner
un certain niveau de gravité des
événements rencontrés en outre il
convient selon nous de prévoir que la
durée de cette transmission n'excède pas
celle qui est effectivement prévue pour
permettre l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre afin de ne pas risquer de placer
sous surveillance continue les parties
communes des habitations
une autre modification envisagée porte
sur le visionnage en temps réel des
images des systèmes vidéo de la sncf et
de la ratp est la cnil demande que ce
visionnage en temps réel soit limitée à
des cas précisément défini et présentant
un degré de gravité suffisant alors en
conclusion je voudrais juste rappeler
que je n'ai pas repris évidemment
l'intégralité des points de la ville la
cnil permettez moi d'ajouter que la cnil
se montrera particulièrement vigilante
aux conditions effectives de mise en
oeuvre de des dispositions législatives
qui seront votés que ce soit au travers
d'ailleurs de l'examen des dispositions
réglementaires qui lui seront soumises
ou dans le cadre de l'exercice de ses
pouvoirs de contrôle et en l'absence
éventuelle de conformité de sanctions le
collège de la cnil a voulu dans son avis
faire un ensemble de suggestions
précises pour apporter un éclairage au
parlement mais avant toute chose nous
nous réjouissons beaucoup que ce débat
puisse avoir lieu si les finalités
poursuivies sont légitimes
les technologies dont il est question et
notamment le recours aux drones sont
intrinsèquement intrusive
nous appelons donc à une vigilance
particulière sur la nécessaire
robustesse du socle minimal de gare
anti à apporter pour protéger au mieux
la vie privée je vous remercie pour
votre attention je fais naturellement
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs à votre entière disposition
pour essayer de répondre aux questions
que vous vous posez
merci aux coréens de la précédente alors
je vais d'abord donner la parole aux
rapporteurs monsieur réservés merci
monsieur le président maintenant la
présidente
tout d'abord un grand merci pour cette
présentation de l'avis de la commission
nationale informatique et libertés un
avis que vous avez rendu public ce matin
et qui a la foi est clair les travaux de
la commission le travail des deux
rapporteurs marc philippe daubresse et
moi même mais également qui éclaire le
débat public je crois que sur des
questions aussi importantes que celles
ci il est utile que la commission
nationale informatique et libertés qui a
reçu deux législateurs il ya plus de 40
ans la tâche de préserver
les données personnelles puissent
prendre sa part à cette à ce débat
public est ici en parlements en
particulier
moi j'aurais pas de questions auprès si
j'ai lu la vie et il y sera très utile
dans le travail de dudu du sénat lors de
cette première lecture de cette
proposition de loi est donc sait c'est
qu'un avis très précieux pour nous et
qui va nous permettre aussi de essayer
de dégager des équilibres nouveau y
compris dans la dans la rédaction des
amendements qui seront proposées à la
commission des lois
moi j'avais une réflexion plus générale
à faire et j'aimerais avoir votre votre
avis sur ce sur cela sur la question par
exemple des drones c'est une pratique
des forces de l'ordre d'utiliser des
drones
les équipements ont été achetés hors de
tout cadre juridique et je comprends
votre votre idée de donner lieu une
expérimentation mais j'ai peur dans ce
domaine de des drones que nous allions
moins vite que l'avancée technologique
et quand on connaît les capacités de
miniaturisation
quand on connaît les capacités demain de
reconnaissance faciale
quand on sait déjà le cas pour des
dispositifs qui existent déjà à
l'étranger
comment est-ce que de votre point de vue
le législateur peut avoir une capacité
d'anticipation suffisante aux évolutions
de la loi qui permette d'anticiper
c'est ces évolutions la de d'accompagner
les forces de l'ordre vers de nouvelles
finalité est d'encadrer ces usages
plutôt que d'arriver je dirai après la
bataille où finalement c'est le conseil
d'état qui est contraint de bloquer
l'utilisation des drones en disant vous
n'avez pas de cadre lui les législatifs
vous devez en avoir un nous ici on a
conscience de ça donc on va doit offrir
un cadre un cadre législatif aux forces
de l'ordre le plus protecteur possible
mais aussi qui permettra quand même
l'utilisation de danse entre deux cas de
figure de ces de ces appareils et je me
dis comment est-ce que de votre point de
vue en tant que qu'autorité de
régulation de ces questions là vous
pensez qu'on pourrait être beaucoup plus
de prospectifs et qu'on puisse vraiment
faire évoluer la loi en intégrant déjà
en 2021 des évolutions je sais que la
cnil travaille beaucoup sur sur des
questions aussi d'innovations et
j'aurais voulu un mois que vous vous
entendre sur ce sur ce sujet là en vous
remerciant de bondues dudu de la vie
très précis que vous avez rendu est
également de votre présentation tim
servez monsieur daubresse
peut-être avez-vous une question oui
j'ai une question de seul président en
saluant évidemment la présidente de la
cnil et on la remerciant pour la densité
de son avis qui est tout à fait utile
pour vous le savez nous voulons que
cette loi garantisse la protection des
libertés tout en atteignant ses
objectifs en matière d'autorité
j'ai une question de la présidente qui
concerne l'article 24 que vous évoquez
de manière à la fin de votre de votre
avis en disant en substance que comme
vous le savez nous nous proposons nos à
écrire et dû rentrer plus tôt par le
biais du code pénal et nombre et et de
sortir de tout ce qui touche à la
liberté d'information que nous voulons
évidemment très énervé vous dites que
venait finalement peu concernée puisque
il a des dispositifs de protection des
données
quand il s'agit aussi de dispositifs
d'image ma question est simple est-ce
que vous pensez que les dispositifs
actuels qui régissent la protection et
la diffusion des images qui sont tournés
à la sude un certain nombre de personnes
sont suffisantes pour protéger par
exemple les policiers qui sont en action
en opération ou est-ce qu'il faudra
aller plus loin et si oui avez-vous des
des propositions dans dans semaine et
deuxième chose vous dites à un moment de
votre
vu que plusieurs nouveaux acteurs vont
intervenir dans ce que l'on appelle la
sécurité globale à la fois les policiers
municipaux qui voient leurs prérogatives
étendues udecam champêtre des policiers
de sécurité privée est-ce que vous
pensez que nous devrions encadrait
beaucoup plus leur capacité à lire des
images et comment se dit ces dispositifs
peuvent s'articuler
est-ce que les préconisations actuel de
la cnil sont suffisantes
merci à la porter à vous laisser la
parole
merci monsieur président donc si si je
réponds dans l'ordre si j'essaye de
répondre alors merci beaucoup
donc d'abord aux observations de loïc
hervé
alors des drones ont été achetés j'ai
cru entendre d'ailleurs de la boule du
ministre l'intérieur que ces achats
avaient cessé en tout cas pour le moment
compte tenu de l'absence de cadre
juridique en tout cas c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré devant votre commission et vous
avez pointé le vrai sujet permanent de
la régulation qui est notamment dans les
domaines qui sont les nôtres et qui est
de ne pas arriver après la bataille
c'est vrai en matière de dopage si leur
matière d'informatique c'est vrai dans
beaucoup de secteurs il ya il ya quand
même un certain nombre de principes et
de garantie qui lorsqu'ils sont
suffisamment souple et et en même temps
forte permettent en tout cas sur le
moyen terme de prévenir un certain
nombre d' usage qu'on ne souhaiterait
pas se voir se développer
vous avez évoqué à un moment la
reconnaissance faciale le collège de la
cnil a bien noté au paragraphe 36 de
cette délibération que dans la mesure où
la reconnaissance faciale ou la
captation du son par exemple les
interconnexions n'était pas mentionnée
dans le texte de la ppl
il va sans dire que ces usages sont
prohibées et la cnil a préféré justement
le dire expressément dans son avis donc
il ya peut-être que déjà une des façons
de
de répondre à ça c'est peut-être pas
nécessairement effectivement de vouloir
c'était un peu le sens de mon propos
lister des cas d' usage par exemple
extraordinairement précis mais pouvoir
s'adapter et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle nous appelons à ce qui est une
expérimentation d'abord d'une durée qui
vous appartiendrais de préciser un bilan
une évaluation rigoureuse et puis une
doctrine d'usagé qui par définition
dépendrait du responsable de traitement
il pourrait évoluer en fonction des
usages parce qu'on voit que la
technologie vous vous l'avez rappelé et
évolue très vite et quand on parle de
floutage par exemple si on veut éviter
que les drones et visionnent les entrées
d'immeubles ou l'intérieur des domiciles
on sait que ce sont des sujets
compliqués parce que l'intelligence
artificielle permettra probablement dans
des délais assez proche si ce n'est déjà
le cas dans un certain nombre de deux
cas d' usage de toute façon dans quelque
sorte revenir sur ces conditions tout
âge peut-être pas pour la perception à
l'oeil nu de l'opérateur du drone mais
mais mais en tout cas pour la machine
donc je pense aussi et c'était une des
réflexions du collège de la cnil qui
faut être très attentif aux conditions
de formation des opérateurs de ces
drones attiré beaucoup leur attention
sur la protection des données ce qui
peut être fait ce qui ne peut pas être
fait à avoir un certain nombre de lignes
directrices en quelque sorte à dire que
l'identification des personnes dans
l'espace public notamment doit être
réservée aux cas pour lesquels cette
finalité nécessaire j'imagine qu'elle
est nécessaire quand il s'agit c'est une
des finalités de prévenir et de
poursuivre les auteurs d'infractions en
même temps est-ce que c'est nécessaire
pour réguler les flux transport ou pour
prévenir les risques technologiques ou
naturels j'en suis pas convaincu que
donc je pense qu'il ya quand même un
travail dans le détail à faire autour de
socle de garantie qui serait
déclinée et en l'espèce on arrive
peut-être pas quand même tout à fait
après la bataille parce que certes nous
avons pu constater des vols de drones
mais d'abord ils ont été quand même
interrompu à un moment et par le conseil
d'état et par la cnil dont la décision
de la formation restreinte du mois de
décembre
interdit au delà même du périmètre du
concept de ce sur quoi ça tu es le
conseil d'état lusage en tout cas des
drones jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient pas
d'encadrement législatif donc je pense
qu'au contraire toutes les parties
prenantes sont sont assez mobilisés par
rapport à ces usages pour les garanties
à adopter est effectivement l'article 31
de la loi informatique et libertés ne
permet pas
voilà des traitements de police sans
l'intervention d'un texte et donc je me
réjouis vraiment beaucoup de
l'encadrement qui va intervenir en ce
qui concerne les drones en tout cas pour
l' usage des forces de l'ordre alors
pour essayer de répondre à marc philippe
daubresse sur le premier élément de son
intervention sur ce que pense la cnil de
l'article 24 si j'ai bien compris de la
proposition de loi qui concerne la
pénalisation de la diffusion des images
de forces de l'ordre dans le seul but de
nuire à leur intégrité physique ou
psychique
c'est vrai que la cnil consciente des
compétences qui sont les siennes n'a pas
fait de longs développements sur ce
sujet qui concerne principalement la
liberté d'expression et peut-être des
autorités plus compétente que nous sur
le sujet en revanche que ce que le
collège de la cnil a voulu pointer c'est
que l'enregistrement et la diffusion
d'image de forces de l'ordre ou de tout
élément identifiant d'ailleurs
indépendamment du visage constitue des
traitements de données à caractère
personnel et que donc leur éventuelle
diffusion dans le seul but de nuire à
l'intégrité physique ou psychique des
policiers ne constituerait pas une
finalité légitime au sens de la loi
informatique et libertés indépendamment
des considérations pénales qui
pourraient rentrer
en ligne de compte voilà ce que nous
avons voulu dire sur cet avis sachant
qu'on peut imaginer puisque le débat
beaucoup tourné autour de la liberté de
la presse que naturellement les
journalistes ne diffuse pas des images
dans le seul but de nuire à l'intégrité
physique ou psychique des policiers mais
ça c'est un autre débat qui n'appartient
pas particulièrement de relever voilà
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur ce que
je pouvais dire à ce stade
merci beaucoup merci à une intervention
une question de monsieur john durham
merci messieurs je vais d'abord
commencer par vous remercier puisque
nous avions nous avions écrit le
président avec marie pierre de la
gontrie et patrick kanner pour qu'on
puisse auditionner la présidente de la
cnil et remercié la présence de la
présidente de la cnil et la qualité de
la vie qui nous a été transmis qui est
extrêmement riche
et qui appelle à la fois de la nuance
dans ce que nous en ferons et puis
qu'est un peu vertigineux de la nuance
parce que je je vois que dans ma région
encore cette nuit il ya eu 20 cas
d'agressions racistes qui a été révélée
par des images de vidéosurveillance est
censé sans ces images
sans doute la victime aurait été tel
plus gravement atteintes
et puis vertigineux parce que finalement
le champ des questions que vous posez et
gigantesque je sais pas si finalement la
loi sécurité globale suffira à répondre
à tous ces sujets si j'avais l'oeil
sombre
je verrai dans ce que vous nous avez
transmis à la fois un risque de
banalisation de la captation de flou sur
les finalités d'imprécisions des
garanties et de complexité des régimes
d'accès aux images
et sur ce dernier point je voudrais
faire référence à une affaire qui a été
rapporté par mediapart
ça s'est passé au bois de boulogne des
jeunes gens qui ont été interpellés par
la police qui ont fait figure d'accusée
pendant 18 mois jusqu'à ce qu'à
l'audience
on découvre grâce aux images qui avaient
été prises leur innocence et une
incorrection dents
les actions des policiers qui les
avaient interpellés
du coup est-ce que vous pensez que
l'effectivité de l'accès aux images et
garantit aujourd'hui qu'elle est
suffisante
est-ce qu'il ya pas beaucoup de progrès
à faire dans l'accès aux images par les
personnes concernées qu'elles soient
d'ailleurs forces de l'ordre vous l'avez
dit sorting 24 ou ou simples
particuliers et ça me semble être
finalement ce débouché de toutes ces
images qu'on capte par différents moyens
un des sujets centraux de nos débats à
venir si monsieur merci beaucoup
monsieur le sénateur alors sur
l'effectivité de l'accès aux images en
tout cas c'est un point sur lequel la
cnil est particulièrement vigilante
d'une façon générale dans la plupart de
nos avis il ya de longs développements
sur la politique d'habilitation qui est
habilité à accéder quelle est la
traçabilité de ces accès pour qu'on
sache qui a accédé à quel moment et
c'est donc ce que
si j'ai bien compris le sens de votre
intervention vous vous insister sur la
nécessaire transparence des informations
qui peuvent être diffusés via des images
collectées par la vidéo nous l'avis de
la cnil ne critique pas du tout la
nécessité de cette transparence
d'ailleurs vous aurez remarqué à propos
des caméras individuels ou des caméras
piéton qu'il est prévu que soit diffusé
ces images dans le cas
dans un objectif d'information justement
du public sur les circonstances de
l'information autant nous souhaitons
préciser ces circonstances autant on
peut comprendre que ça participe d'une
relation notre grande confiance entre
les forces de l'ordre et la population
est justement peut-être aussi de
s'extraire un peu de la culture de
l'extrait en quelque sorte qui est
parfois parfois seulement celle des
réseaux sociaux donc sur sur le principe
on a pas de sujet en revanche le vrai
sujet pour nous c'est celui de
l'intégrité des images qui se peuvent
servir justement de justification nos
preuves etc
et il ya un certain nombre de procédés
techniques qui font sur lesquels il faut
être particulièrement vigilant et à mon
sens qu'il faudra prendre en compte
notamment dans le texte réglementaire
pour garantir que ces images ne fassent
pas l'objet de modifications qu'elle ne
soit pas supprimée qu'on sache qui a
accédé
voilà donc en tout cas il y a puisque je
crois que la notion de continuum et
quelque chose de qui est souvent employé
à propos de ces questions de sécurité en
l'espèce il ya aussi un continuum entre
les dispositions législatives
réglementaires et la pratique je pense
et le contrôle de la cnil pour le coût à
sur lequel il faut être particulièrement
vigilant e
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que le régime de la
vidéoprotection en général a prévu un
régime d'accès aux images qui est
protecteur et qu'il faut chercher
naturellement ici également à prolonger
sur l'ensemble des sujets qui sont
abordés
merci monsieur là richard hénault
président moi je me livre est vraiment à
des considérations assez latéral je n'ai
pas eu le temps de prendre connaissance
de la vie je n'ai pas de mal à être
convaincu d'avant ce qu'ils veulent nous
aider à bien fixer le cadre légal de de
ses différentes utilisations non mais
j'aimerais souligner que nous sommes
sans doute je rejoins ce que disait
jérôme à l'instant nous sommes sans
doute à la veille
d'une assez forte extension de 8 à 6
l'utilisation des drones
parce que avec maintenant vingt et
quelques années d'expérience nous voyons
les limitations des caméras fixes
à bien des égards par rapport aux
objectifs à la fois de police
administrative et de police judiciaire
qui sont les leurs les caméras fixes
comporte des limitations importantes et
dans la première quand je me place
plutôt seul angle judiciaire et la
vulnérabilité physique des caméras
lorsque elles sont apposées à proximité
de lieux de délinquance organisée
leur durée de vie généralement de
l'ordre de la semaine
donc il y a et c'est un coût important
dont il va y avoir une intensification
de la demande sur la base de
dispositions législatives mais qui
seront acquis seront fixés de
l'utilisation de drones en remplacement
substitution de caméras fixes qui ont
retrouvé leurs limites
j'évoque en prévision de réflexion et de
proposition loi qui peuvent devenir un
sujet complémentaires là encore avec une
très bon
comment dire un objectif plus de
judiciaire que l'administratif
c'est les atteintes à l'environnement
par définition dans les endroits où se
produisent des actes ont changé un peu
de qualifications pénales mois faction
des atteintes à l'environnement
il n'y a pas de caméra fixée au général
on est dans des espaces inoccupés et
tous les élus locaux
se sont retrouvés là même eu des cas
dramatiques avec des situations
conflictuelles et généralement
infructueuses de poursuite de thé très
nombreux dépôts sauvages des projets
illicites et caetera et avec la
possibilité jusqu'à présent dans la
jurisprudence judiciaire de le prouver
par voie images on a travaillé sur ce
sujet là mais il me semble que sur le
sujet par exemple des dépôts sauvages
évidemment le drone apporte une solution
j'aurais vous simplement ce que j'avais
une première réaction sur ce sujet là et
puis c'est un sujet vraiment pratique
mais qui adore junior pas les les effets
juridiques c'est que la limite
traditionnelle dans lequel on y habite
les deux peluches plus combien d'années
de des deux semaines de durée de
détention initiale de conservation
initiale dans la vie pratique d
la police judiciaire du quotidien est
vraiment limitative et moi j'ai été
témoin un grand nombre de fois dans le
département le chu d'angers élus de
situations dans lesquelles le la mise en
route de la procédure pénale la
désignation d'un enquêteur la
vérification de d'appréciation initiale
de l'importance des fêtes abouti à ce
que la première demande du commissaire
du coin ou de la brigade de gendarmerie
de consultation des images arrivent le
seizième jour comme par hasard et donc
je me pose la question de savoir si au
fond d'un point de vue de voile à
l'équilibré les principes que vous avez
mission de conserver la prolongation ou
un trois semaines ce volet de cette
durée initiale de
de conservation ne serait pas un outil
l'équilibrage du dispositif
merci monsieur chat madame resort merci
monsieur président ce ministre 8 donc
effectivement sur la première partie de
votre intervention le fait que les
drones vont de plus en plus probablement
se substituer aux caméras fixes nous
sommes bien conscients effectivement de
ce mouvement
et c'est précisément la raison pour
laquelle il est quand même important non
pas de s'opposer à une technologie par
principe à partir poursuit quand elle
existe et qu'elle présente le cas
échéant un intérêt mais précisément de
dire que les caméras fixes et les drones
en matière de vie privée c'est pas du
tout la même chose et que donc il ya des
finalités tout à fait légitime
il convient d'être bien conscient de ces
différences importantes alors sur
l'objectif judiciaire qui vous évoquez
notamment par rapport à l'environnement
je pense que ça rentre mais me
semble-t-il sous votre contrôle je parle
sous votre contrôle dans la catégorie de
la finalité qui est relative aux
infractions à la recherche des
infractions et à la poursuite de leurs
auteurs
qui pour laquelle la cnil ne trouve rien
à redire si ce n'est qu'il faudrait
peut-être définir plus précisément cette
catégorie d'infraction parce qu'on peut
se dire que pour une voiture mal garée
ou pour des papiers jetés dans la rue
peut-être pas indispensable d'avoir un
drone mais qu'en revanche pour
pouvoir savoir qui fait des dépôts
sauvages en portant atteinte à
l'environnement
ça ça peut être utile donc nous ce que
nous suggérons c'est de préciser les
finalités et naturellement les finalités
relative à l'environnement dans la
catégorie des infractions à mon sens a
toute sa place sur et d'ailleurs il ya
des lois y compris relative à
l'environnement comme la loi anti
gaspillage par exemple on était le
législateur a prévu des dispositions
spécifiques avec de la vidéo qui est
possible dans des installations
spécifiques et avec des décrets
d'application qui sont soumis pour avis
à la cnil
alors en ce qui concerne maintenant la
durée de conservation fait finalement
les deux principes cardinaux de la
protection de la vie privée que nous
essayons de décliner et encore une fois
à travers 7 propose proposition de loi
c'est le principe de nécessité donc là
on vient de parler de la finalité mais
c'est aussi le principe de
proportionnalité et en ce qui concerne
la durée de conservation
le sujet pour nous à chaque fois qu'on
examine des durées de conservation c'est
de savoir si la durée et proportionnée à
la finalité pour laquelle les données
sont conservées et il y à de multiples
exemples pour lesquels il y a une durée
de conservation qui est très très
supérieure à celle que vous avez
évoquées il vous est très modérée donc
au contraire dans l'idée de passer le
cas échéant j'imagine si c'est justifié
de 15 jours à trois semaines sur des
durées de conservation qui ont cette
finalité la donc de mon point de vue
c'est un point qui a réglé probablement
dans le décret la question de la
proportionnalité de deux durées enfin
dans le texte
pardon je pense que c'est dans le décret
d'application que la question de la
durée précise effectivement de
démonstration mais je sais pas si il
soit peut-être que je pense
bonjour sur les dispositions de vidéo
protection classique
effectivement le code de la sécurité
intérieure a fixé une durée de
conservation d'un maximum de 30 jours
concrètement sauf dérogation et
exception l'exception judiciaire étant
expressément visés 1 au terme du csi là
on est vraiment dans des dispositifs
tels qu'ils existent actuellement dans
les cas des dispositifs qui ont été
examinés par par la commission et
notamment ceux qui sont envisagées dans
la pré dans la présente proposition de
loi l'examen de la durée de conservation
s'effectuera au regard des finalités
poursuivies en impliquant le principe de
proportionnalité tel qu'il vient d'être
rappelé par madame la présidente
oui en principe la fixation de la durée
et réglementaires pour la plupart des
pots des traitements prévus notamment
ceux pris en application de l'article 31
de la lille donc pour les finalités
police justice le législateur a estimé
sur la vidéoprotection donc les caméras
fixes effectivement dans le lot de
garanties très important qu'il a mis
dans ce régime l'un avec les commissions
départementales nationales toutes les
règles un certain nombre de règles ou
était monté au niveau législatif et la
durée de conservation est captée par la
loi actuellement le projet de loi ne
fait pas ça pour les drones donc du coup
ça renvoie ou politiques de droite mais
le sénat peut tout à fait décider de 2,2
d'ajouter comme ça une limite sur la
durée de conservation de l'image
pour l'instant le texte ne fait rien du
tout sur ce point exactement et le
décret devra devra faire quelque chose
d'où l'utilité de votre avis et pour les
travaux qui seront menés par nos
reporters et on se rappelle d'ailleurs
que le rapport seront en commission le
17 mars prochain
comme ça les choses sont claires donc
notre objectif ne sert le rapport d
le dit c'est la date du 17 mars rapports
des commissions monsieur le comte et
puis alors monsieur leroy et monsieur le
comte
allez monsieur leroy puis ensuite
monsieur locaux oui l'euro à passer dans
le camp mais merci monsieur le président
je voudrais remercier la préside
merci je voulais remercier la présidente
de la cnil pour ses éclairages et ses
réponses cependant on est déjà on a déjà
franchi le pas des équipements savoir
que tant dans les communes que dans le
certaines certaines forces de l'ordre en
ce qui concerne en ce qui concerne les
drones de nombreuses communes sans son
équipe et ne serait ce que pour
surveiller les massifs forestiers pour
les incendies pour les inondations et
ils sont extrêmement utiles surtout que
les privés ne s'enchaînent pas de de les
utiliser en ce qui concerne les caméras
fixes
effectivement le trois quarts des
mairies qui se sont occupés du c2 que
sont équipés de ces caméras fixes les
ans flouté desk desquels approche une
ouverture privée ou une entrée
d'immeuble mais c'est vrai qu'elles sont
extrêmement utiles pour les
interventions cas de crime ou de délit
ou de d'infraction de 5e classe qui se
commet sur le terrain il faut savoir que
en réalité des images ne sont aix simcoe
l'officier de police judiciaire lors
dans le cadre de la commission d'un
crime ou d'un délit et qu'elles sont
utilisées sous la responsabilité du
procureur de la république en relation
avec l'officier de police judiciaire
territorialement compétent quant aux
caméras piétonne effectivement il y a
lieu de de fixer les règles très
rapidement car de nombreuses communes
aussi se sont équipés ont équipé leur
policiers municipaux qui s'en servait
c'est une leçon déclenché que par
l'action du porteur de la caméra
uniquement quand il y à un conflit avec
un citoyen
et c'est pareil c'est un officier de
police judiciaire territorialement
compétents et non pas le maire celui qui
a une affectation par le procureur de la
république sur une circonscription
d'action qui peut utiliser ces images
pour apporter les éléments de preuve
nécessaires lorsqu'il y à un conflit
avec un citoyen l'an la commission
d'infractions et notamment des dd délit
d'injure voilà si vous voyez ce qui me
paraît absolument nécessaire et
indispensable quant au maintien de
l'ordre
effectivement c'est vrai que c'est une
aide au commandement imparable car ça
permet aux commandants des forces de
l'ordre d'intervenir sur les points
chauds d'une part ou des crimes ou de
délits se commettent et dans l'ensemble
des textes qui sont en vigueur en
interne dans de ce que ce soit dans les
mairies où que ce soit dans les forces
de l'ordre effectivement il ya toujours
l'utilisation de ces images soient pour
redéployer les forces en fonction si
vous voulez de crimes et de délits qui
se connaissent sur le terrain par les
images 2d des droits mais en aucun cas
elles ne sont accessibles à n'importe
lequel des membres des forces de l'ordre
voilà donc je crois qu'il est urgent car
il ya une grosse attente notamment des
mairies mais aussi les forces de l'ordre
de légiférer sur le sujet car il faut
qu'on précise cette utilisation qui est
un outil qui permet d'utiliser
effectivement beaucoup moins de
personnel sur le terrain de gagner du
temps de gagné en effectifs et d'être
efficace que l'on réclame de plus en
plus sur le sujet de la sécurité globale
tu vois là merci mais non merci je
rectifie la commission c'est le 3 mars
entre les dates je sais que tu es
globale les séparatismes on est un petit
peu
la commission 3 mars séance la semaine
du 15 voilà merci monsieur le président
pour pour essayer de répondre à monsieur
sénateur leroy et vous vous posez traite
de façon très importante me semble-t-il
la question de l'utilisation des vidéos
des systèmes de vidéo par les
collectivités territoriales
en ce qui concerne les drones je me
permets en tout cas sur les caméras
aéroportée d'attirer l'attention de la
commission sur le fait que en tout cas
ma compréhension du la proposition de
loi ne traite pas du tout ce sujet et
qu'à ma connaissance il n'y a pas de
fondement légal à l'usagé de drones par
les collectivités territoriales
aujourd'hui
certes la décision de la formation
restreinte de la cnil en décembre
dernier concernait uniquement les drones
mise en oeuvre par le ministère de
l'intérieur il n'évoquait pas les
collectivités locales mais j'ai noté que
dans son avis sur la proposition de loi
au mois de mai dernier je crois aux 70
dernier plus exactement la section de
l'intérieur du conseil d'état a précisé
qu'il n'existe pas de fondement
juridique permettant en gros l'usagé
drôle je passe les termes j'veux l'élite
exact tant par les autorités publiques
que par les collectivités territoriales
et la l'article 22 de la proposition de
loi renvoie à des autorités publiques
dans lesquelles ne sont pas incluses les
collectivités territoriales la sueur sur
sur le deuxième point sur l'utilité des
dispositifs de caméras fixes ou de
caméra individuel notre article notre
délibération en tout cas pour le collège
s'est voulu aussi équilibré que possible
justement entre le
l'utilisation de ces différents s'ils
sont nécessaires pour répondre à un
certain nombre de finalité et en même
temps la nécessité d'être conscient des
attentes qui sont susceptibles de porter
à la vie privée pour essayer d'encadrer
ces usages et d'apporter les garanties
nécessaires donc en fait nous notre
message c'est qui convient sans remettre
en cause un certain nombre de finalité
vous avez très bien exposé exposer nos
passés au tamis en quelque sorte chaque
finalité pour essayer de préciser son
objectif et d'autre part de s'interroger
sur la proportionnalité pour chaque
finalité qui serait nécessaire décade
usages qui serait employé ce que je peux
répondre à ce stade madame la présidente
un petit peu au-delà de du projet de loi
portant sur la sécurité globale
je vais interroger sur les les trois
décrets qui ont été pris le 4 décembre
dernier et qui ont complété le code de
la sécurité intérieure et qui ont mis en
place donc trois fichiers de prévention
des atteintes à la sécurité publique ou
les activités politiques ou les
appartenances syndicales pourront être
indiqués même si au début de l'année le
conseil d'état a considéré qu'il n'y
avait pas d'atteinte fin que c'était la
démarche et les décrets n'était pas une
atteinte à la légalité
quelle est votre position sur cette
évolution parce qu'il semble que c'est
bien la première fois que l'on considère
qu'une une opinion politique mérite
d'être fiché parce qu'elles
représenteraient en elle-même à danger
pour la sécurité de l'état
que pensez vous de cette de cette
rupture et de la manière dont les choses
sont encadrés pour ne pas représenter
pour notre pays un risque démocratique
majeur la présente merci monsieur
président donc monsieur sénateurs pour
essayer de resituer les choses un peu
dans
leur contexte la cnil dans le cadre de
son programme annuel de contrôle 2017 a
qui étaient en partie consacré officier
de renseignement à contrôler les trois
fichiers que vous évoquez le fichier asp
qui permet de faire des enquêtes
administratives pour des personnes qui
accèdent à certaines fonctions ou à des
lieux sensibles et le fichier parce que
j'y passe collecte d'informations dans
un but de prévention enfin en tout cas
de protection de la sécurité publique à
la fois pour la police nationale c'est
le pasp et le gie passe pour la
gendarmerie nationale nous avons
diligenté 16 contrôles entre
[Musique]
septembre 2017 et juin 2018 dont 15
contrôles sur place ce qui est assez
considérable au regard des ressources de
la cnil et à la suite de quoi le
ministère de l'intérieur a fait évoluer
ses décrets pour les rendre cohérent par
rapport aux pratiques que nous avons
constatées et nous avons notamment
veiller à ce que les en termes de
finalité les atteintes à la sûreté de
l'état soit mentionné puisque ces
décrets il datait de 2009 et 2011 et que
naturellement les choses ont évolué
depuis le contexte de la menace
terroriste aussi les missions des
services l'entrée en vigueur du rgp des
donc nous avons demandé que soit précisé
clairement cette finalité ce qui nous
permet nous après dans compris à
l'occasion de nos contrôles d'identifier
clairement les données qui sont
collectées à cette fin notamment
et puis nous avons beaucoup insisté et
sur la nécessaire précision des
catégories de données qui étaient
connectés pour que ce soit plus précis
alors sur le point spécifique que vous
évoquez telle était la situation avant
l'intervention de ces décrets qu'elle la
situation après avant l'intervention de
ces nouveaux textes qui sont parus
effectivement tout début décembre et
pour lesquels la cnil a rendu un avis le
25 juin mais les avis de la cnil sont
publiés en même temps que les
et décrets comme vous le savez il était
prévu il faut distinguer si vous voulez
les questions de principe et la question
de sémantique les principes qu'ils ont
relativement peu évolué il pas évolué
dans la mesure où la collecte de ces
données existait déjà c'est pas une
création de fichiers avec la nouveauté
qui serait la collecte de ces données
est par ailleurs en ce qui concerne le
périmètre
si on reprend l'ancien formulation sur
les activités il ne s'agissait pas c'est
juste factuelle de collecter les données
correspondant à l'ensemble des activités
politiques philosophiques religieuses ou
syndicales mais celle de ces données
correspondantes à des personnes qui sont
susceptibles de porter atteinte à la
sûreté de l'état
ça c'est sur les principes maintenant
s'il ya eu une évolution sémantique que
vous avez souligné on est passés donc
des activités de la collecte de données
sur des activités politiques
philosophiques religieuses et syndicales
à des opinions politiques et
philosophiques a des convictions
religieuses et à l'appartenance
syndicale
cette modification sémantique elle n'a
pas été soumise au collège de la cnil et
elle n'a pas été soumise et qualitative
j'en profite d'ailleurs parce que vous
m'en donnez l'occasion d'une certaine
façon et je vous en remercie monsieur le
sénateur pour faire un peu pété une
petite précision sur ce que sont les
avis de la cnil
la cnil rend des avis sur un texte au
moment enfin en l'état du texte qui lui
est soumis et par définition ces textes
sont susceptibles d'évoluer
c'est le cas de la vie que nous avons
vendu sur la proposition de loi on peut
espérer qu'il évoluera
et c'est le cas également
potentiellement sur des projets de
décrets par ailleurs j'en profite aussi
pour dire contrairement à ce que
j'entends quand même très souvent que la
cnil ne valide pas ou ne valide pas
n'autorise pas ou ne refuse pas les
textes pour lesquels elle rend sur
lesquels elle rend un avis c'est une
sorte de facilité de langage qui ne
correspond pas à ce que sont nos avis
qui ont vocation à éclairer autant que
possible dans la compétence qui est la
nôtre avec le prisme protection des
données est respect de la vie privée le
pouvoir réglementaire ou le législateur
et vous avez
très juste titre rappelé que le juge
administratif qui il appartient au juge
administratif effectivement de contrôle
et le cas échéant lorsqu'il en est saisi
la légalité des actes réglementaires sur
lesquels nous avons pu le cas échéant
revendre un avis et je ne doute pas que
le conseil d'état rendra un avis au fond
sur ce sujet au delà de la procédure de
référé que vous évoquez où il a été
indiqué qu' en l'état de l'instruction
le conseil d'état n'a pas eu de doute
sérieux sur la légalité de ce texte mais
sur lequel on sait en ce qui concerne
l'évolution sémantique que vous évoquez
le connaître de la cnil n'a pas
q n'a pas été en mesure en tout cas de
rendre ce jeu là c'est à dire une
opinion mais en tout cas on était de se
prononcer sur le sujet merci madame
on sait pas si jean importante ya type
[Musique]